olha vai
bora lá pessoal vamos ver se o cliente
compra se conectar e funciona em preso
25 vai a esses músicos sua hora e temos
o lado pessoal de quem fala ao dar só
ela é e sejam muito bem vindos mas um
beijo e hoje pessoal o experimento vai
ser muito louco ao experimento deus te
ver com extintores e porquê porque hoje
nós vamos tentar tornar um carrinho de
compras nunca o super rápido com o nitro
ele sentou vacinômetro um dos carros
mais rápidos do mundo atualmente tem 450
quilômetros por hora mas isso não é tão
impressionante sempre se eu tiver em
linha reta ou fica lá há algum tempo e
atingir essa velocidade mais
impressionante disso é que há casos que
atingem 100 quilômetros por hora em
apenas 2 com 22 8% no caso 11 2% ambos
por horas até que a idéia foi a partir
de então eu vou tentar construir um
carro muito rápido também é claro não
vai ser rápido como ficarem muito rápido
mas eu pensei como eu tenho alguns
pintores e os podem ser usados como se
fosse uma botija de nitro por que não
juntar setores com que a gente compra só
poderá ausentar
mas antes nós fazemos diz primeiro
diante de vocês verem eu quero explodir
uma grande grande ajuda só investir
muito laquê neste vídeo série de times
muito laico máximo blog vocês
conseguirem é porque o youtube agora
funciona um pouco por white então se
vocês não deixaram aqui neste vídeo os
meus vídeos não vou ser recomendados
para vocês
então achei muito mais que mesmo porque
se vocês conseguem ver os meus vídeos e
eu assim também pensa certeza que vocês
vão ser os meus vídeos já sabem se vocês
forem nós aqui no canal subscreveu um
canal que ir lá fora então pessoal mas
antes de tentar aqui construir um
carrinho eu vou tentar fazer que o
experimento que estou muito curioso e eu
ainda não vi ninguém fazer eu acho eu
vou fazer aqui um texto com nossos
pintores que vão ser potenciado eu estou
aqui a estrutura estréia o cinto não
voltar pra fazer um experimento com e
seguidores que possa levantar só esse
tempo aqui detentor so2 portanto não
surgir nada e cheirar joão sequeira
mesma que eu não sei na verdade legião
seco porque consegui extrair joão
sequeira sustentou então não vale a pena
dizer que isso é perigoso e eu muito bem
ser é 13 já sabem o pessoal este
experimento vai ser quente por isso não
façam isso em casa
jorge e me trouxe aqui coxim mas não
faço em casa quem é mas eu vou
aproveitar o fato de um filme muito frio
aqui por dentro para tentar continuar
com o nosso ela que shitake modo que se
olhe o que nós vamos fazer é só apontar
o instrutor e vamos ver o que vai
acontecer será que vai continuar será
que não vale o que eu vou fazer agora
este texto mas que quiserem ver um vídeo
dedicado só continuar coisas com
extintores mantém a creche e nos
comentários
eu sei fazer com que esse comentário
muito embora o modelo é minha mesmo
profissional
a ram e agora é muito simples é só
apertar o cinto por cima deu e vamos ver
o que vai acontecer só eu posso puxar
aqui vocês para mais perto é assim ele
está provavelmente 321 vai meu deus meu
deus é mesmo gil é uma camada de 15 é
mesmo o chão seco só vou tentar
musculares têm água ou eu tenho que
nunca foi
vamos fazer a fumaça uau é mesmo de um
circo nelson que só vou tentar mais
tempo 321 vai
é aquela coisa só quantidade ou take meu
deus está completamente congelado ou daí
a sua cruz no esta camada já não sabe
que condenou ovos um só até a ponta do
cinto está congelado olha isso por aí
ponto lata branca não só como vocês
viram dá pra usar o buc xiii-2 quiserem
cup deste experimento com vários objetos
comentem e agora que sabemos que pudesse
do nosso instinto por oito fazer o
experimento que lindo com prince com o
nitro eu quero deixar aqui o meu grande
obrigado a criar outro palmela é porque
eu não gostar uma pista de karts deus
pra fazer esse experimento base que me
deu nenhuma pista gigante de kart só pra
mim muito obrigado mesmo e para lá pra
pista de kart olha só porque da pista de
karts o estatuto só pra mim e vamos
fazer aqui a experiência com nosso
escritor embora vai funcionar
cuidado não era
é bom você já sei o que é que isto vai
ser né
não há pessoal depois desta queda vamos
lá então fazer com que o nosso primeiro
já tenho que nós que ri e os nossos dois
pintores as espadas é tão maluco é
porque é maluco
de um lado o rápido tempo de creche e
agora vai estar pronto para 31
o utah funcionar a lei 32 um prazer
estar certo eu vou ter que ganhar os
dois tentos
assim enquanto dentro do carro pela
equipe também vai ajudar fazer este
experimento na i miev se o cliente
compra não aguenta com isso para fazer
este primeiro acreditou conta com um
chip pessoal como é que vai ser o plano
já está a fugir então eu vou entrar aqui
dentro usar o extintor com um propulsor
que o pib vai dar só um empurrãozinho
aquela início só depois vamos ver se o
nosso instinto faz o trabalho pois me
descuidar por isso o jogo lá e cá o que
salgado bem
não não é pequeno hotel que o leitor
quanto na casa do gaúcho é nosso
primeiro só agora qualquer forma o
primeiro tentou então vai ficar é que
assim bem posicionado e os contentores
vai ficar muito mais câmeras dentro não
sai pi não sai não faz ideia mas vamos
tentar agora não mas é melhor aqui não
aqui
não é porque é uma zona mais nisso ok
mas nós vamos fazer o experimento aqui
porque é uma zona mais lisa e eu não
quero que esta curva que influencia o
sofrimento
então vamos fazer disse que espera mas
como é que tu vai conduzir o o carrinho
eu não vou é porque se eu apertar e
silva à esquerda se importações pra
direita então vou portanto ela é o poder
de propulsão se sabe que lá só para gaza
agora como é que você entrar e sair para
votar o escritor pegar qualquer limpe
sua próximo por ter mais potência e eu
vou ficar aqui as cabeças ainda você
está muito mais concentrado foi cantada
por um sobre o parceiro super propulsor
eu vou conseguir ultrapassar o carro
mais rápido num só com sintomas após eu
sic eu acho que só vamos ver se o
cliente compras com o nitro funciona em
32 o pai
sob o capô
i
agora conseguimos fazer o que o
experimento isso funciona mesmo assim
estou muito rápido mas o cantor junto ao
juízo tô nem aí eu não consegui sair em
ajuda bicho
agora vamos brincar de opinião não foi
por aí não posso cair logo na estreia
só agora vamos apresentar a minha queda
pouco melhor ou não vocês puderam ver o
pessoal de muitos gostam que muitas
vezes é mas no fim deu tudo certo e eu
consegui andar com o quinto compreendam
funcionou no experimento é e com essa
brincadeira toda é de fazer um
experimento eu já tinha gasto muito co2
sustentou então como vocês puderam ver
não só consegui andar tipo os dois
metros de nomes e mandei muito pouco
porque já tinha gasto em torno então o
pessoal não quer voltar a ter este
experimento mas com carinho muito muito
maior
um campeão talvez construído por mim e
com muitos mais setores que têm todos
também maiores e totalmente cheios
cuidar que faz o supercarro cintura e eu
vou fazer é o que mais pessoas tenham
gostado sânscrito aqui no canal em
escreva e yes we can vai até a próxima